o iPhone wallpaper plena Ponte Estaiada
leite eu vou ver ele é
meu nome é Stop de Souza só pescador sou
aposentada
um adolescente de 32 tô com 88 anos
eu tenho uma mulher chefe e filho quatro
mulheres e três homens
e na Barra do Sul antigamente não era
bagulho Suelen Araquari pertencia para
ti me fazer futuro né as coisas muito
difícil
e quando eu comecei a a iniciar a pesca
aí acredita é só a vela tem mulher mas
ela não tinha motor
E aí é companheiro quatro horas da
madrugada pescar pegava lá voltava dois
diz que é o 300 cada um cortava para
trás renovável e Vinha vindo a remo se
tinha vento minha corrente não tinha
eu chegava em casa entregar o texto e aí
é estendeu-se Pinheiro novamente e
recolher o outro dia ela acha tudo
peixinho do peixe corvina habitaram
bocado coroca bagre choveu que viesse
mata um
no retorno todo dia
é só perguntinha motorizado era cinco
pessoa aqui que eles vão para o peixe de
nosso Pescador e levá-lo para ele não ir
depois colar no então aí sobrou que nós
podemos comprar um motorzinho de se vai
Play Store e aí comecei a moto também
apertar com motorzinho
E aí vai melhorando
tá melhorando melhorando a festa aí
e depois usar no Banco do Brasil
financiou
o aparelho pescador para lavadora eu
pescador filho empréstimo cinco anos 60
dias e aí comprou em vai Cascão e motor
e pagava Porã
há mais ou menos 500 30 anos
há 30 anos
a baleia a baleia foi diferente
e aqui era uma realidade falar em pesca
de baleia nós ia falar muitos anos que
tinha festa da baleia nisso aqui por
perto Imbituba tinha pesca da baleia lá
e lá com a farda da baleia então vieram
os homens uma pescaria de lá patrão a
valer em Barra Velha
E aí outro ano vier eu quero matar um
aqui com a filha dele Canoa E aí eles
foram eles trouxeram aqui dos pescadores
dele tudo mas chegou aqui eles paravam
na casinha ali tudo equipamentos usados
voador queimador os colega dele aí teve
uma noite de outro amigo ali a entregar
o Faltou dois tripulantes procurado foi
embora crédito aí Faltou dois homens aí
esses dois olha que passou aí nós dois
ele colega por não Egito e
E aí perguntar se nós fui aí nós temos
que queria vai ver Me aguarde aí forma
os outro e embarcamos ou a valer tá
perto dos Tamoios Aí terminou a peça
E aí playboy outro alergia novamente
pegar novamente aí no segundo ano
E aí afirma de Joinville tinha comprado
a baleia dele nós pegamos um Ferro o
homem colocar o dinamite e fui morar na
firma oferecendo afirma disse que dá um
material todos nós tiver aí Castelão
contratual
e térmica isolante de Joinville e aí no
segundo ano pegar o negócio da Mata
mandou hoje é assim levar uma longa usar
trabalho afirma a primeira emoção foi
muito porque o povo vier a baleia estava
aqui pertinho aqui aí fumar um
a usar pão era feito arpão de 50 cm com
a lança acordada na ponta e aí ela sabia
três bananas de dinamite
bom então quando chegar lá perto da
Baleia e a Rafaela primeira ele ficou
vou dar um pouco de parede de fotos
quando dava oportunidade a gente ficava
ali que ele pegava os que eu tinha
enasarco alto é muito perigoso aí nós
passa no quarto por elétrica com fio de
eletricidade e sem médico aí então mais
atuava que quando ela sorria vai levar
aquele cavernas por
é mais passo perto do Motorzinho do
Store é muito lega a noiva era muito
pesado levava tempo levar o 45
motorzinho aí ele conforme a distância
levar uma qua
E aí até a praia depois outro dia
começar a desmontar ela levado em 12
homens Nós trabalhar elevador de rei vai
dar pronto
ir para praia não tem eu começava a
cortar cortar aí ela servia não a carne
e nem o dota não seria tudo internada é
só aproveitar ele trancinha gravar fazer
o óleo Esse óleo montando o proprietário
da firma para nós com a parte a palavra
Oratório EA outra parte era tão com a
mecânica Olha o mecânico 200 Tamoios
o sabor e oriental só que aproveitava
o tambor de 200 litros
e acabou de moleque
e porcas descarta e a carne e os ossos
enterrados e me matava três quatro tava
doido
o outro lugar é aparente não ia
embarcação fazer vou
eu consigo ir até em Matinhos no Paraná
formatar um aí foi puxado por Curitiba
pela BR 101
ou menos 50 6x
há 58 peraí ai depois veio a
a ver o
eu falei que ele não Brasil não podia
matar mais aí foi parar de todo lugar
e depois eu vou um ano doido para casca
para não parecer mas depois continuou
vendo para ver como vem agora novamente
esse período ali que nós tava nós não ia
pescar outras coisas vai passar os
período Marli e a Outra profissão dele
pesca de corvina dentro de painha tem a
pesca da Corvina da Tainha da da em soa
a época do colchão que é dia de outubro
até Março aí nós pagava lá na aí ele
está bonito tá lá três meses quatro
meses
Olá primeiramente eu fui para Santos
quando eu tinha 22 anos que é muito na
Ponta da Praia em Santos a depois vindo
êxito além 58
há 58 eu fui para a Cidade de Peruíbe
e depois de chegar de Peruíbe Oramos
juntos tempo lá botão novamente para
Barra do Sul mas sempre a casa tinha
aqui aí minha esposa não foi aí de lá de
Felipe agora eu vou ter pescar em
Cananéia que o leitor ali Cananéia ali
na Ilha do bom abrigo cara né aí ela
ficava em casa mas eu ia ficava também
trazer ele de ser tempo até dezembro aí
em dezembro nada embora para a ilha é
o município de Guarapari ali é muito
pouca cada ele era muito dificultoso.
Não tinha Estrada Estrada só de carroça
de até lá pegar o trem e para Joinville
Jaraguá do
eu só aperto aperta lá emprestado para o
Joãozinho plantar uma rocinha fazer uma
farinha magret o colheu uma flor vai dar
o produto que tá na Bahia ou fora
e assustou só que eu passei vai
trabalhar em Cananéia eu fui anunciar lá
o balão Aí nós damos um laço
e a rede gatona um troço lá o navio
perto da praia
Oi e aí eu achei era muito pescadores
sabia muito bem minha muita coragem
fumar mas na danada lá por aí A Canoa
Virou se eu fiquei em cima da Canoa
acabou mandou para fora e perfuraram
tarde tudo na dar o pastel e aí lá fora
eu achei que ia morrer aí eu tava em
cima daqui agarrado meio transmar grande
veio uma voz no meu ouvido e disse pode
para frente para frente para frente aí
eu ouvi não me lembrei lembrei quando eu
cheguei na sua conta
Oi e aí acabou fugindo fone do rodou e
bateu na praia
eu não queria o único mais perigosa que
eu passei lá
e até alguma coisa que eu vou estar ela
quer ficar um
a vontade
é aquilo que fazer uma pessoa a pessoa
gosta e
Oi Marlene aqui nasci para ser pescado
em